The second of Kruchten's views is the developmental view, and
here we're concerned with the source code.
The logical view had to do with the system,
primarily with how it's going to execute.
The development view has to do with the source code.
And the units of source code which might be considered for
modeling in the development view include packages, classes, subsystems,
libraries, files, and so on.
UML package diagrams, UML component diagrams can convey this sort of thing,
as can the mechanisms provided by source control systems such as CVS or,
or, or, or some of it's SVN or, or Github or some of the more
modern modern systems allow the developers to break the system into modules.
Here is a reminder of some of the slides that we saw when we were
reviewing UML diagram types.
Here's a class diagram with packages, here's a package diagram, and
here's a component diagram where the rectangles correspond with the components.
The the arrows correspond to specific
dependencies among the components indicating that a component
supplies what is needed by a component at the other end of the line.